we want to listen to the sound of your
voice ren
peter and jake this is the red
peter and jake
we're here to listen to the sound of
your voice
sound
how's it going guys what's up man
peter dude what is on your hat man it's
a raccoon with a piece of bread son
get that bread you never had a hat with
a raccoon and a piece of bread on it
no i've never had a hat with a piece of
bread on it
you've had a hat with a raccoon on it i
also haven't had a hat with a raccoon on
it right have you heard are you a
raccoon
um no secrets are being spilled here
whoa everyone thinks he's a cat
but i actually think his spirit animal
is more like a raccoon
runs a dog with hands
so how does one go about getting an
ironic hat with a
raccoon spread on it the secret is to
have a really awesome sister who
will make you this for christmas i was
about to say i was going to say etsy
it might as well be that's essentially
etsy is just like
you know individual craftsmen making
making things crafts people no yeah she
made a bunch of hats for my whole family
like
my brother had one with a dinosaur on it
these are like little embroidered
patches she put on i love it it's my
favorite hat
presents that you can make are
simultaneously
the best because they're really great
and personable and also because they're
usually cheap
it's also the gift that keeps on giving
all year round you can just
keep putting it on every day you walk
out of the house and every day you're
like hey
guess what i got this going in my life
i'm always a big fan of the uh 9 p.m
michael's runs
christmas eve looking for like arts and
crafts [ __ ] to make for my family
is that is that a common occurrence in
the france family every every
year every single year really at least
for me
because i'm okay a procrastinator
so you you both you both and your sister
both make presents
yeah pretty much i don't know why it's
kind of a tradition we started a long
time ago we like
make presents for each other did she
make you that painting behind you
no that's my brother's painting that's
one of his album covers
he did that one it's like all ripped
apart because the paint was so wet and
it was like normal paper it just like
fell apart
how many siblings do you have i was i
was just about to comment i didn't
realize you had a brother six sisters
yeah you're lying no i got one of each
okay yeah are you guys all artists
sort of my brother's like a musical
artist and my sister is in social work
so she's a
an artist of the people an artist of the
mind and the soul
yeah exactly yes check check doing god's
work
um that's cool that's a nice thing to do
i think my microphone sorry i think my
microphone was like blowing out there
for a bit so
sorry uh listeners i you'll have
very clippy rent audio there but it
should be fixed now
ran don't worry there's a thing called
post production uh see what you can do
is before we export the final file of
this video
uh you can go in adjust your audio
settings so that
it's lower even though it'll be peaking
you know we'll lose a little data
it won't blow out the ears in the old uh
you know well i had a limiter on my
recording so it's like it's not gonna be
loud it's just that there's a lot of
lost data just like it's gonna go
wow so guys um all week you guys have
been working on uh
these well horror effects like this
so yeah i've been working on on some
effects that were pretty fun not gonna
lie
i don't know if people know how we got
to this point in this video i don't know
if we've talked about it on the vlog
or on the crew channel i don't even know
how we got here
so well so just to just to give a little
background on this
uh we so we have
we have an agreement if you will with
black rifle coffee
and they're like hey you know you
basically
we keep you guys on you know basically
effectively what is a retainer so that
we can like consult with you guys and
create with you guys
and so you know about once a quarter or
so we come around and we're like okay
what do you guys want to make
what do you guys want to make right now
um and they were like uh okay we've got
all these ideas we want to make uh
uh this one that's like a parody on
uh gun control it's like a gun control
parody
video cause you know that's that's what
they do so we're like hey that sounds
funny we can get behind that
uh what it was gonna be was gonna be it
was gonna be called
medieval atf or something like that
where like
there's a bunch of guys walking through
uh alcohol tobacco and firearms
it's a government agency um so
anyway so there was a bunch of people
walking through uh like a forest
and as they were walking through the
forest they were getting stopped by
these medieval soldiers who were then
like
complaining about the length of their
blades and like the width of the handles
and like
you know all these parodies to like
modern modern gun control
and it was pretty funny we had like a
pretty good script going that was like
you know i spent a lot of time crafting
it i didn't want to make it like
you know too much of like an outrageous
like hey you know screw these people or
screw those people i wanted to make it
like a funny
you know like bright commentary on the
state of affairs you know yeah that's a
really
fine line to balance there yeah and so i
spent all this time writing
um i even i even got to a point where i
was writing this video
and uh i uh i had a patio chair
on my deck and i took it and i was i was
frustrated with what i was riding one
day and so i went outside onto my deck
and i took this patio chair and i just
threw it off the deck
onto the into the yard i just like
hugged it over there
and then i sat down on another chair and
i was like okay
you shared new ideas and i and i and i
looked at that chair
in the yard and i said i'm not gonna
pick up that chair
until this video is done
that's hilarious so jake this story is
funny because
i don't know anything about that that
idea
that previous yeah yeah this is the
first time hearing about that so why is
that jake
so this also brings up something that i
kind of wanted to get into with you guys
which is like kind of how we work in
tandem but also not
necessarily at the same time on things
um
and i thought that that'd be interesting
for you two guys but
uh so so how is that how has ren not
even heard of this process so far
because this is all happening on the
production side
so like you know pre-production
is the entire process that that i'm
talking about right now like
we had been consulting with them they've
been talking with us they've been
talking about ideas
sam and i have been sharing ideas back
and forth with like matt
and jared over there and we've just been
you know every now and then we'll get on
a phone call and just kind of like
hack through ideas throw ideas at the
wall see what's
funny you know just kind of have like a
writer's meeting
and so this is one of the ideas that
came out of that and then i said okay
that sounds funny i'll take a pass at it
and then i've realized very quickly that
taking a pass at this script wasn't
it was super nuanced right and it
required all this kind of like
writing and revising so anyway long
story short i spent about two weeks
off and on writing this piece and then i
sent it over to him
and they're like okay this is great uh
you know here's some notes whatever
sam took a pass at it we had we had what
was like
a a a shooting script right we got it
all the way to there
so i was like okay we've got a good
shooting script now is now i'm gonna
turn take my rider hat off i'm gonna put
my producer hat on
and i'm gonna go around the state of
texas and i'm gonna
talk to like so i called adam lyons and
i was like hey adam
we got this medieval production um
you're the guy
right because wren do you remember when
we were in austin
uh in 2012 we saw him on a billboard
what yeah just random we're going down
the highway and i was just like
that's adam
expert right yeah so yeah so his
profession
i don't know if he still does this i
don't wanna say profession
by day at one point was
you call it the nickname for it is like
a pickup artist
he's a dating coach but really what it
is is it's a dating coach you take
you take usually guys who like don't
know how to really interact with women
and you you go through like the
fundamentals and you're like okay this
is like
you know what what people like and don't
like and this is how you can approach a
conversation and this is how you can
talk about yourself without sounding
like a jerk and
da da da da it wasn't really so much
about being a pickup artist it's just
like hey
yeah you could use a little bit of help
yeah and so people were like
uh what was it was that one movie uh
hitchhike yeah hitch yeah
so well that was a movie from that was
15 years ago
and he yeah right peter you haven't seen
hitch
guys okay fine i've seen it like 10
times jesus okay thank you
thank you we've all seen it okay
okay isn't ava mendez in it yeah
i mean that's all you need to know right
there
all right i'm in okay so anyway so adam
lyons an old friend of ours who used to
live in l.a
who is from england by way of
south who who's he's well sorry he's
from austin
texas by way of south africa by way of
england
so he's yeah so anyway he's got a really
interesting past we should have him on
sometime because he's
like he's an insane human being in a
very in all the coolest ways
yeah he has a really interesting story i
remember listening to his like rocket
jump
podcast back in the day like a million
years ago yeah
his dad uh was a like a like a
what do you call it uh like a bare
knuckle boxer
whoa and he had he had a left hand
that like had metal in it
because his dad had had some kind of
like surgery or something like
and it made him really good at boxing
and so so the doctors put like metal
in his hand and he used to knock people
out with his left hook
in these bare knuckle fights but no one
knew that he had metal in his in his
in his fist oh my god that's
that's right there well
[Laughter]
legality to it uh
but anyways um where i was going with
this whole thing it's like yeah
yeah he's super into medieval fare
yeah so much so that there's like
there's a place
in austin well it's actually in bastrop
which is outside of austin
called the sherwood forest fair and the
sherwood forest fair was started by this
man named george
and adam lyons used to play robin hood
at this fair and the same would be robin
yes because he's got the english accent
he's got the charm
you know he's got the suit already and
so he just shows up there and people are
like oh my god are you robin hood and
he's like yes
i am which is a total adam lyons thing
to do
you know and then just like because of
that
became robin hood of the fair
oh my god he would take money from
wealthy people
well well like no like legit he played
you know do you know how medieval fares
work
so like there's there's usually there's
usually like uh
there's a lot of culture to it and and
usually within the culture of a medieval
fair
there's like a storyline happening where
like you can
follow different participants uh that
are like live-action role-playing
around the fair and they'll be like
there'll be a whole backstory to it and
they'll be main characters and they'll
be characters that come in and out
so you can kind of wander around in like
medieval garb and drink like medieval
ale
and watch things and watch sounds so
yes peter's over here thinking that
you're going to show up and might get
robbed
no no yeah
oh man you should do that on node that
sounds like a great time yes
um i believe they have actually yeah
yeah
um so this guy george
built this he built a castle he built
like
grounds they have actual jousting
matches that happen there
with guys that are in full like 14th
century
medieval night armor that are literally
hitting each other off of horses with
with lances oh my god yeah
uh and so i got connected with all these
people
through adam and he like you know he
brought me around and he introduced me
to like george who's like
george obviously built the place so he
plays the king you know
he plays king henry and then there's
this other guy raul that's like one of
you know one of the one of the other
maine nights and
i went around all these guys are super
friendly awesome people
like they hooked me up with like
thousands of dollars worth of their own
personal
medieval equipment that just just just
because they're so into it right and i
told them that we were doing something
medieval and they were like yo
what do you need um because they're
awesome
and so then i get all this together
and the sunday we're supposed to leave
on a monday i know the next part of this
story i hadn't realized you had
you had gone so deep down this path
oh my god i wish i could pick up this
camera right now and take you guys out
to my garage because i have
my entire have it all
i could outfit a small army of medieval
soldiers right now
from my garage that's hilarious and so
okay so yeah the sunday so then it's
sunday and logan
from black rifle calls me and he's like
hey um
so uh we want to pivot on the medieval
idea
um because halloween's coming up and
we've been doing these slate
this slate of of horror veterans versus
horror pieces
for every halloween for the last couple
years and they've been performing super
well
so we don't want to do the medieval
video anymore we want to do
veterans versus horror three and i'm
like wait so you don't want to
use any of this stuff and they're like
no
so now i'm like
so i've got like i learned so much i've
got like medieval spy handers which are
like these
german long blades that are meant for
like chopping horses legs off and i've
got like
nightly arming swords and i've got like
sugar loaf helmets from the 13th century
and i've got
full body chain mail and cauldrons and
like
but is there a raccoon with bread on the
helmet yeah
so yes and then one of the crests is a
raccoon with bread
that's amazing i'm there that's you get
me in that suit i'll
fight anybody that's your sigil dang
so moral of the story you guys ended up
shooting a completely different video
when you got out to texas that you
started figuring out basically the
moment you arrived as opposed to all of
the
two weeks worth of work that you had put
into it beforehand yep it was more than
two weeks work it was like a month of
work
must have been painful yeah i mean i
kind of knew
you know like that that
not that that was gonna happen but i
knew we filmed with them so much at this
point that i understand like
they're constantly changing things last
minute and that's also kind of just a
good
habit to get into not not the habit of
changing things last minute but the
habit of understanding
and adjusting for things that changed
last minute because that's how
all productions work there's always
somebody at some point
like you know whether it's like sam just
rewrote the
commercial script that we're filming
next week yesterday
and then and then sent it out and so
round two
well i mean if you ever have to rewrite
stuff and you don't get
if you ever have to rewrite stuff and
you're not able to get it on camera at
least you could just throw in some like
stock footage to cover it all right
yeah totally so so anyway so we get on
the plane
and just just to segue into the vfx part
of this which i'm about to do
we get on the plane and sam sits
everyone down
and he's like daniel bring over the
camera i've got something to tell
everybody
and he goes guys
today's episode is brought to you by
[Music]
storyblocks
okay but seriously it is
hey guys it's that time in the episode
where i tell you about today's
sponsor story blocks they're the
one-stop shop for all of your stock
asset needs so every time we're working
on a project and we need
b-roll motion graphics after effects
templates sound assets and more
we head on over to story blocks through
our unlimited all access plan we go to
quarter cast storyblocks.comcast get our
assets we put them in our videos
we're done we move on with our day the
best part is that it's all royalty free
it's all in beautiful 4k and the
extensive library keeps growing so
you're never going to use the same asset
or need to use the same asset twice
we can use it in commercial projects we
can use it in youtube videos
instagram facebook youtube our own
website
storybox has us covered whether or not
you're already a professional creator
or you're somebody that's just looking
to start out and you need
a place to go to add b-roll or other
stock assets to your content
storyblocks is by far the best place to
do it and that's why they keep
sponsoring this podcast because
we keep using them around here and it's
just a cool tool that i want to tell you
guys about if you're interested
head on over to storyblocks.com
corridorcast
and check it out storybox.com slash
quarter cast all right
back to the podcast and now we're back
um
so anyway so no but he tells everybody
that
uh we're not gonna film the video and
daniel filmed a whole story about that
which i'm hoping we can get out on the
vlog
uh which brings us to where we are today
which is now you guys for the last week
or four days or so i've been working on
visual effects for let's be horror
and there's some pretty funny things you
guys have been doing like uh the face
reveal yeah i just i just finished the
second shot for that and i've i've never
done like sort of a
it's like the mission impossible like
face mask effect where the face peels
off but the original face kind of like
crinkles up and goes off
um yeah yeah i just took a look at it
looks
fantastic you really nailed it very
pleased with it very pleased with it did
you follow
like a a mission impossible type
like code of of creation for this
or did you just kind of go about it
i have no idea what that means what that
means i know i wish i could
open up the briefcase and like yes put
in some numbers and started 3d printing
the face and i actually have to had to
do a photo scan of that 3d printed face
i mean that's not enough to do appeals
honestly
yeah like with red was it was it a
mission impossible intro scene
where like you opened a briefcase
it had a scanner in there and then they
were like
you need to scan this face within five
minutes and decide
or this mission will be terminated and
then
you did that yeah if i didn't finish the
effect in time my computer would explode
there you go that's what i was looking
for
[Laughter]
no but what i mean is what i mean is um
did you use the mission impossible
shots as inspiration or reference
not really honestly i didn't look at a
single mission impossible shot i've seen
those movies before i remember how they
look
but yeah what i mean how you guys filmed
it is that like
you had one person with a mask on like
this actual
mask that is huge by the way that was
the hardest part just painting out this
huge mask
uh but like following like so you
actually did
a good job with like pulling the mask
off and having like a good cutaway point
for the hand to reveal
the face and whatnot and i just kind of
like distorted a plate of the next of
the original person's face
onto that uh uh and i distorted it with
like a puppet pin tool
tracking it off kind of thing it was all
manual no tracking work done there but
you hand distorted it yeah oh
yeah it looked good yeah and you added
like some fabric texture or something on
there right i just did that on the
second one
and uh yeah i literally just took uh an
image of what looks like like bed sheets
uh white bed sheets and i just set that
to like multiply
on top of the face and like fade on as
the face starts getting
uh but like in a precomp so as like the
distortion of the faces being distorted
those uh folds are also getting
distorted with the face
[Music]
clever girl
[Laughter]
yeah i've barely been working on this
one i've just been like oh yeah you've
been working on a crew video
yeah i've been redoing the glitch vfx
because i looked at that i was on the
corridor
channel one time and i saw the glitch i
was like what is this glitch
this sucks and so i was like i'm gonna
redo this and you guys can find a way to
re-upload it
how old were you when that video came
out it would have been december 2012.
i think i was like four
i was four no you were not
you were dying you were like yeah i was
13.
okay yeah oh my god
i was about to just end this podcast and
go home
like he was about to have a panic attack
probably like
20 times i can't overstate enough
how much like corridor had an impact on
me as a child
like as a young teenager molding your
mind
no seriously i really looked up to you
guys for a long time somebody met you
and i was like
someone took a screenshot of a comment
that you made
i want to say like eight or nine years
ago no
uh it was a message from you to me being
like hey
you're a big inspiration if you ever
need any help let me know
oh my god what video was that
i don't know i think it was a channel
comment someone went to your channel and
went and like sorted by oldest to new or
whatever
and found something it was on our
subreddit like a month or two ago you
know what happened is that back in the
day i made this like half-life 2
fan film definitely copying you guys and
i tweeted it at you and you saw it this
is before we met each other
and your years were nice enough to click
on some random dudes
video and watch it the whole way through
you gave me like vfx notes on it
it was amazing wow
i remember giving you a note that i've
since learned it wasn't a good note it
was like you had the sharpening turned
on
whenever you just turn on sharpening uh
it like it adds like this one pixel
border of whiteness
around the entire video and i was like
just scale up your footage by like point
five percent and it'll get rid of that
but that's that there's a better way to
do it you add motion tile and add in
uh underneath the blur or the sharpening
scales it out
yeah exactly you tile it out and then
you can add the sharpen uh
effects like fast blur have that built
in or just like repeat edge
pixels or whatever it's the same sort of
idea yeah i was like yeah
ren i i know that already i i know
bro
well you didn't back then i figured it
out about 15 minutes after you gave me
that bad advice
yeah and then you ended up uh becoming
an intern for us in 2016
mid 2016. we had just started the vlogs
they were still like low view count like
we were like
wow today's video got 35 000 views
that's amazing
whatever you wanted they seem
so high production value and now looking
back at them
they're they're like janky but like
sweet janky
they have more character because there
was a lot more just uh
genuinely captured moments as opposed to
all right everyone we're gonna film this
bit here
uh and but they were also way shorter
like those videos were like two to four
minutes
back in the early days of 2016. because
he's like people like you used to
release so many more videos it was every
other day
whatever happened to that well
technically we release a lot more
content
just in fewer videos you know it's like
if you're to add up the weekly content
the amount of content we've been putting
out every year has consistently gotten
higher and higher
and i'm talking just on the crew channel
and i'm not even including
a visual effects artist react
yeah no totally um the
thing that we used to do was just cut it
and and and drop it like there wasn't
even music
and basically we didn't even have music
for like the first four months
really i mean there was some stuff it
depended on michael yeah
yeah he would pull stuff from the old
like channel music that sam had wrote
but we didn't really have music we
didn't really have uh
like any sort of theme or philosophy
behind like
how or why we were telling stories we
were just kind of like it was true vlog
style which was just turn on the camera
and go which is
which is great for certain stuff and i'm
super glad that we
have that again with crew cuts on the
site because
we we get we're starting to get a little
bit of that back and the people that
want that
it's there you know and and i think i
don't know there's some charm to it like
looking
even even like looking back at yourself
or like others
in it a year later you can see how
people
change and get better or you know and
and
and i think that's cool about it yeah
it's interesting
it's like a living time capsule it is it
really is
yeah yeah definitely the um
the thing that uh you know
reason why we kind of got away from it
though is because uh
people just want to see more people want
to see these like vfx
and filmmaking centric videos which to
me was a huge surprise to be honest but
it's it's all about the execution
i think it's more about trying to just
tell stories because that was one of the
things i remember nico really kind of
identifying and focusing down on it's
like
we can continue doing we can continue
covering the stuff we're doing in daily
life
but there has to be a story and yeah and
that story has to like you know
have all the regular arcs of a story you
know beginning middle end
payoffs all this stuff uh so whatever
journey that is it can't just be like oh
and we're doing this right now and then
we're doing this and there's like no
payoff for any of it there's no setup
context for any of it
it's just captured slice of time which
if we're just
hanging out joking around doing
something fun that's all you need
but for it for to like for videos to
actually be good they needed some sort
of story and
and so like over the years that's kind
of what we started focusing more on as
opposed to like we're just gonna
take a one wheel versus a hoverboard
today yeah
yeah it was like the perfect um like
precursor to the more modern videos
because it
you guys learned how to tell stories
like like find a story in literally
anything and so now yeah that's such a
valuable skill to have for
making money if we didn't go through
those couple years of just capturing
everyday stuff because that was what we
ended up finding is that like we'd
capture a bunch of stuff and it's like
this sucks this isn't
interesting this isn't making a good
video and after putting out uh
enough videos where you're like this
video didn't have to exist and it's not
really entertaining
300 of those we decided
yeah well that was the other thing it
wasn't like we just changed overnight
this was a very gradual evolution over
the over the course of the last five
years even before the vlogs existed i
mean the vlogs
came out from the previous year or two
of like behind the scenes content
um even though at the beginning of every
year for like like beginning of 2017
beginning of 2018
we'd come out the video with being like
all right we're changing things up this
year we're gonna do it this way
and then we kind of didn't change
anything it was still like that slow
evolution of like okay we're focusing on
new things
but because we made a video talking
about
the things we're gonna change everyone
latched on to that and we're like
you guys were better before you made
this new change this year
and like i want the vlogs for from last
year i want i want
yeah i want brett and his mustache thing
back again
that was like hilarious great but uh
we've we realized that we can't announce
changes
anymore like that not within like story
fundamental like
story arcing like that yeah yeah
because then and then you might decide
especially to in the artistic process
like sometimes you're wrong
and sometimes you you try you go down a
road
and then you're like uh you know what
actually this isn't this isn't how i
like how it looked when i wrote it down
on paper so like we need to we need to
add this or we need to change this or we
need to go back and we need to
take this exit to go to this story
instead and that happens all the time
it's just part of the process but when
you but when we pointed it out people
people caught on to it and then they
were like oh wait you said you were
gonna do this
you're now you're doing this yeah yeah
you don't want to lock yourself into
just like
how about this we'll give you guys good
stories and then
there'll be good videos yeah that's
ultimately what we realize is that like
as long as we are just trying to make
the best content that we can
people won't really complain we're just
on this mission to create good content
right
right and it turns out most people who
watch our content
don't know how to make it but they think
they
do and so they have criticisms
and feedback that isn't particularly
useful
yeah you know it's it's easy to get down
about that
and like but you know honestly it's like
people people complain about it
not that they're you know but people
complain about it because they care
and because they're because they're
attached to it because they it means
something to them
you know and i think that's a sign of
that you're doing something right
at least that's what we tell ourselves i
don't know if you guys find this but
i find that the only comments that
actually bother me are the ones that
have a little bit of truth in them
because yeah when people are just saying
awful things it's like whatever that's
just an internet comment but when
there's like
a little nugget of like oh that's kind
of right it just stabs you right in the
corner
i should have changed them
[Laughter]
yeah or when it's like a nugget of truth
mixed in with a lot of
like misinformation or like
misinterpretation or assumptions and
she's like no
no what are you doing stop that i hate
when they make assumptions and
assume that they're right anyway um and
one
i want to talk about another thing
regarding since we're on the uh talk
about all these
you know vlogs from back in the day the
concept of seasons
in our vlogs was something i don't think
any of us ever really
paid attention to or understood it was
because every year
uh we'd finish the vlogs and like the
next year we'd go through more vlogs and
then a year after that more
content and but those those videos would
get put in a playlist
and i forget who did this for the first
time it was like right season one was
that was that year and then the next
year um
season two so they became these seasons
and
over the course of those years no one
ever talked about seasons but i've
noticed this year as more and more
people are
are like finding our content and going
back through the back catalog they start
talking about oh yeah season two is
great
or like oh yeah i remember that one
video i think it was in like season
three and i'm like
seasons what are you talking about i
don't even crazy
it's weird for me to like comprehend
that there are seasons of this stuff
it makes sense because corridor puts out
so much
content and like so much more than like
a tv show has like 20 episodes per
season
nine seasons or whatever it's like
corridor has like way more episodes per
season so it's good to have some kind of
organization to it
yeah yeah and there is some truth in the
to talk about
nuggets of truth in there there's
there's truth in that
each year our creative process does kind
of repeat itself in the sense of
we do a year of work and then you know
we kind of look back and we say okay
here are some things that worked here
are some things that didn't
here are some things we want to try this
year based upon that
and then we you know we then we try new
things and that kind of hap
that cycle kind of repeats itself
naturally every year it does
that is very true every january we kind
of like re-evaluate what we want to do
this year
what kind of things we want to focus on
for instance 2019 was my year to do
those science videos
yeah and and like i i focused a lot on a
lot on that
last year but this year i my desire to
pursue those videos hasn't been as high
as my desire to pursue these project
build videos you know the nerf drone
jan's finger
the ice ice cube face thing like
that's where my energy has been this
year i've still made a couple of those
science videos
but it's just like it's just not as a
primary focus as it was last year
yeah you've been wanting to do ice cubes
for a while i had one i'm glad we
finally found a moment to
i know that was fun i've literally been
wanting to do that for like more than
half of this year and finally i was like
wait
this thing can make us can let us do
that
i'll just wait till everyone's in texas
then i'll have my chance
i can still taste that tomato soup oh me
too that was
so bad i really enjoyed the first few
bites and then i was like
well i love tomatoes i'm a big fan but
something about changing that
temperature to be frozen
like a popsicle destroys
the experience so much i can't even
describe it because the flavor is still
there but
the texture and the experience is so bad
yeah i took one bite out of that i was
like nope i regret this with every fiber
of my being
so i think that's why people refer to
the show with seasons
because it makes sense it kind of does
and it's that way
um but you know like
it's funny because it's also caused some
internal confusion
from time to time on our side
like um you know with the introduction
of crew cuts
as a as a true vlog again we had to
take a step back creatively and make
sure that
we're not telling the same stories there
that we are on court or crew
now corridor crew i think we've got a
lot better foothold on like what that is
and what it is not
than we did like say a year or or a year
and a half ago when vfx artists react
kind of took off
there was sort of like a a
like a coming-of-age moment for that
channel i guess you could call it
yeah where we we we very quickly
realized like wait a minute
what do people like about youtube uh
people
that are specialized in different things
in life
pursuing goals
that are within that field and like you
know
the expose of them that you can't that
you don't necessarily get from like
television
that's you know closer to real life than
than reality tv
and we were like wait a minute we're
doing that with vfx artists react we're
we're doing in or at least as like a a
catalyst
for all these other things that we can
do with
all of the post-production skills that
we have in the studio
and then we very quickly realized that
there was a direct one-to-one
correlation between
people that like that show and people
like that like
seeing us create different things in
post
taking things that are already existing
and then bringing them to life in other
ways
and then obviously ren you've kind of
got your own like little
creative niche within that which isn't
necessarily that but
like i'm just a wild card you kind of
are you're like our yeah
and so it just made sense it's like
well that's what people want to see on
this platform we enjoy making them
so why you know
why continue to do a vlog that's going
to get 30 40 000 views
and be really really interesting to that
audience but then also withhold you from
accessing a much larger audience
on a platform that's totally tailored
around large audience viewership
so that's why i think we have a nice
balance now because people that like
the vlogs can watch it on the site yeah
and those aren't going away but so
speaking of the crew cuts yeah i slept
on that for a long time
uh i just recently caught up
like over the weekend i i watched most
of them i haven't watched all of them
yet
but like i just the main reason is that
like
i i haven't trained myself to actually
visit
corridor digital.com yet like i have an
account because i work here
but like i never actually went to the
website to like watch stuff because i'm
like i already watched the stuff
as it gets made you know and then like
oh the youtube video dropped i'll check
it out see whatever final
things were changed usually i'll
probably just check the comments
uh but like with the crew cuts it's its
own show that's
separated from everything else and i
hadn't
i hadn't it basically gone over my head
so then i was like you know what i
actually probably watched some of these
things and i started watching them
they're like
they're really good they're really funny
daniel's killing it with these episodes
and it's like curious
he's really good at getting those
editing in i love the i love how he's
been adding in
the the like the discord chats you know
he's making it from scratch like he's
not screen capping anything he's just
got like this template for like the same
colors and text boxes
and the fonts and and all that stuff and
he's basically just recreating those
moments that we
are having uh in real time or like where
we're chatting
yeah he's just recreating them so that
the audience can experience them it's
really cool
it's so great that's such a fresh take i
was like man i got it
it's just like there's all this content
that's being made about like
our daily life at the studio and in the
vlogs and whatnot and i just
hadn't watched any of it because i kind
of didn't know it existed
it's really fun having a tv show as
egotistical as it is having a tv show
about yourself it's like the most
interesting thing you could possibly
watch
[Laughter]
yeah there's there's some trippy things
that happen with that like
so i've trained myself i don't watch
anything on youtube anymore i'm like
totally the opposite
now oh whoa i take the app
and i and i and like because we have an
app with chromecast
and so i take it and i just sit down
like
and you know i like watching sports but
you know sports games once they're over
like usually there's like an hour or so
before i actually go to bed so i'll just
go on the app
turn it sling it to my tv and then like
catch up on
stuff that i haven't seen yet that's
been released
like usually it's note episodes crew
episodes
i see all the vlogs because daniel and i
are constantly working on those but
yeah so it's funny that's what i meant
by like
talking of having that conversation
because we're it's interesting because
you're wren you and i are like on
opposite sides of like
the same like like galaxy or like
a solar system
[Laughter]
we have opposite orbits yeah like they
they they can they contra
they cut they counter balance one
another you know
well i'm the reason why i mostly watch
our all of our stuff on youtube still is
like
that's my primary form of entertainment
in general like i watch way more youtube
than i do netflix or hulu or hbo
granted uh lately we've been working
through a backlog of
shows we just finished watching umbrella
academy we're almost done with the boys
but usually my go-to uh form of
entertainment just throw on youtube
okay i follow a lot of youtubers a lot
of youtubers
usually ends up making quite a bit of
content and so every day there's usually
new videos that i'm super down to watch
and that's
most of my entertainment comes from that
yeah
including our content yeah now that's
funny
my favorite thing is uh is on a friday
night
logging into the quarter crew account
and then playing those videos that are
going to come out over the weekend like
the
react episode and then like say the
sunday video and i'll just watch them
back to back friday night
and i'll look at the video and they'll
have like one view
two views yeah and i'm like in 24 hours
this video will have a million views
and that's just a really really weird
thing to like just
come to terms crazy yeah
so what are you guys gonna do
um when uh
when the first site get when the first
video on the site
gets more views than a video on youtube
do you think that day will ever come
i hope that day comes because that means
good things
you know when did you ever listen to the
podcast where nico was talking about the
um
the bacon with harley yep
or maybe it was the cheese or whatever
that was his like
his goal of like making it was by his
mate bacon right
yeah that was a while ago right
yeah it was a harley interview uh it
wasn't a harley interview it was like
nico
talking about a moment when back in like
2011
when harley and his crew came fill it
yes i do remember yeah he's like i will
finally have made it when i could buy
that big pack of babies yes
so that's my pack of bacon moment is
like the first time that a video gets
more
it can't even be the podcast i don't
care but when the first time that a
video gets more views on the site than
it does on youtube
i'll be like hmm
okay i think this means obviously
excluding crew cuts or any exclusives
obvious
obviously i'm saying like direct direct
because the moment for that on court or
crew
was the moment that we got two videos
with a hundred thousand views back to
back
oh that was when we got uh carmichael
was like all right you can get a new
camera
yeah yeah we said it we said we can't
justify getting another canon 80d
camera until we get two videos that
get a hundred thousand views back to
back wow oh wait no this is even before
that this is just to get the 80d
because we're uh cmic was still using
the fs100 the sony camera oh my god
i love that thing and it was like really
kind of starting to die
on us yeah it was he broke the lens
doing a smash zoom on the behind the
scenes for drone star wars this is like
middle of 2016.
uh and i was like well okay i can't use
this lens anymore it was one of the only
lenses working on that
camera and it was around that time that
we got the add hey you know it was a
great video that we did that first year
that i really want to redo
in like a bigger way is uh archery golf
do you remember okay i do yeah what was
that
we we went out to the park and we
basically like
played archery golf where but instead of
instead of um
uh what's that called when you use the
frisbee
disc ultimate disc golf yeah so it's
like disc golf it's kind of like disc
golf but you use
archery the the the archery tag
disc golf disc golf disco
it's like disco frisbee golf yeah
um frisbee golf so uh but instead of a
uh like a basket target you know where
you throw the frisbee and then it kind
of like lands in the thing
you was a person yes you use a person
i remember because i got hit in a place
that wasn't nice
oh yeah so yeah so you have a person go
out and you're like okay it's a par
three to hit peter or whatever
and then you you shoot and then you know
you have to hit the person
and then whoever's got the highest uh
score for that round is then becomes the
target because you know in golf you're
trying to do low score
that sounds fun yeah we should do this
super fun we should totally do that
again
it was it was a blast and it and like i
watched that video on the site the other
day
because i was kind of like randomly just
kind of
perusing old videos uh-huh and that's
and
so yeah it's just funny to have that
experience like years later
that's cool did we know i didn't know we
had the whole backlog on the website
yeah there's the whole backlog we're
working on the entire node backlog right
now oh my goodness
um so that's see the thing is that's
over a thousand videos
uh that uh we have on node
that's nice there's almost a thousand on
corridor crew but they're thankfully
we've got most of them backlogged except
for everything before the vlogs
which isn't that many videos um
which is so funny because i i remember
thinking it was so many back when i was
making those videos
because uh back in those early days of
corridor and quarter crew i was making a
behind the scenes video every week but a
corridor video was coming out every
other week so that meant
every other week i had to come up with a
new video to come out and i remember
thinking
how do we maintain this frequency of
content i don't know there's so many
videos
[Laughter]
yeah ren you were the you were the sam
and nico channel master for a while
you had yeah for a couple years there
and then you took that early days who
would you pass it on to john angie
yeah it was john angie dude there's a
there's a there's a little tradition
there on that channel
of like you know like you you
had it angry had it uh
carmichael nick nick um i'm i'm sure i'm
missing somebody
no that's basically it okay because it
was like
i was doing behind the scenes for a
while then uh i
i basically started doing full-time
corridor stuff uh effects and directing
but um it was around that time that
carmichael got hired on and i was still
kind of doing some of that behind the
scenes content but then he started
helping me and then more and more he
started doing more of it
and then like an entire year goes by and
then he's like all right we're doing the
vlogs
or he he didn't say that we collectively
are like we're gonna do the vlogs
and see mike's the guy to make him yep
did a great job
that really was i think probably the
biggest turning point
was january 2016.
when do you think we'll have another
moment like that do you think it'll be
this year
well okay i guess the second biggest
moment was probably the start of the vfx
artist react
yeah yeah last year yeah it's easy to
look back though
and it's hard to know it's hard to know
those moments when you're in them oh
it's totally
it's easier to see them after i just say
i think that the start of the vlogs is
probably the biggest one because that
like single-handedly set us on a new
course of content that created
everything that was
has been possible since then but the vfx
artist react
was like the birth of this whole new
thing it was the start of like the
biggest growth our channels had ever
seen
uh or at least the crew channel
consistency
i'm really bummed that we didn't rename
the channel to salmon eagle
salmon eagle yes i remember that i know
if you guys want to see the corridor
crew channel renamed to salmon eagle
for one day let us know in the comments
below
that reminds me i forgot that quarter
crew actually
we can put a thing out on the site that
that petitions for this
we can put out a site petition
if enough points contribute to the sam
and eagle change that we'll call
every we'll call all of our channels
salmon eagle for one day
and there'll be a special logo oh my
gosh a special logo
of a salmon eagle
[Laughter]
beautiful maybe i had forgotten that
nico was really against the name
uh uh corridor crew for a long time
cause we went
probably a couple years trying to figure
out what we should rename the sam nico
channel
he always felt that it was too generic
and i said yeah
that that was perfect because people
always all referred to us as a crew
anyways
yeah i was i was on board with quarter
crew since the beginning i was like this
is great nico what are you doing why do
you things like
and then you can't
put off the decision for three months
and turn that into two years
[Laughter]
you can't win them all you know can't
make every decision
this month sometimes it needs time you
know
and that's that's how that happened
well guys i really enjoyed talking about
some some old school corridor crew
salmonella yeah brother some some
talking about that
not as a participant but as an audience
member
peter i mean you know it's funny i i
consider you like
an old school employee but at the same
time
i think any one of our new employees has
probably put more
days into working for corridor than you
have
because you're like all right a summer
then gone for two thirds of the year
then another summer then gone for
another two-thirds of the year
yo peter man i feel like i've known you
my whole life man
it's been weird you know it's been weird
yeah
it's been it's been an honor i mean look
you
yeah you were there dude you know when
it was just it was me
nico mm-hmm sam ren
and see mike yeah that was it the old
days
those were that that was just we would
just show up every day and be like
what are we doing today guys working out
a sweat city
yeah sweat city usa don't miss that
but yeah that reminds me i'm actually uh
putting my two weeks in so this is my
formal
get out of here get out of here i've
been with you guys for two months
uh so that's enough um i'll be back in
like
what 10 more i got some like laundry to
do
and stuff so yeah yeah well
this was a good chat yeah yeah good chat
friends
and uh great working with you hell yeah
here's you got more work to do tonight
man yeah i'm gonna be working late
[Laughter]
yeah you got i think you got yourself uh
into another
vfx predicament i think
just a self-sabotaging personality trait
i have and i think i secretly love it
that sounds very san franciscan of you
i'm gonna like that
like should i see someone about this
well jake do you want to do an outro
song for us oh yeah i'd love to oh
okay that was the rant peter and jake
podcast oh i could do better than that
that was the wren
peter and jake podcast
[Music]
that was the wren peter and jake ran
peter peter and jake
peter did you know that my middle name
is also peter
no way my middle name is jake watson
and